celui de trafic de données en prison ma
d'années que le consommateur doit
connaître effectivement une sanction est
cette option c'est une amende importante
qui sera remise par les forces de
l'ordre lorsque vous aurez une barrette
de shit sur vous un gramme de cocaïne et
voilà et ce sera vrai dans les quartiers
de créteil comme dans le 16e
arrondissement de paris
et je veux ici dire que bien sûr qu'il
ya dans des quartiers des endroits où le
trafic existe et c'est le travail qu'on
a voulu illustrer ce soir dans le
val-de-marne
il ya aussi donner vos quartiers des
gens qui font vivre ce trafic en
consommant de la drogue
alors ça peut apparaître sympathiques
comme ça la première vue et de loin
c'est évidemment extrêmement négatif
pour l'ensemble de la concorde nationale
et chacun désormais doit être
responsabilisés et à partir du 1er
septembre
tout consommateur qui sera pris avec du
cannabis ou avec deux copines connaîtra
cette amende que mis en place par le
club